well more than 80 000 people have now
been flown out of afghanistan since the
taliban takeover charlotte bellis has
been talking to afghans who are still
trying to leave outside kabul's
international airport
the countdown is on as the us and
foreign forces now only have until
tuesday to get out and with that means
the end of evacuation flights and here
outside the airport there is panic
there's people rush to see if they can
get on some of these final flights and
we understand the us and the taliban
have a deal that the taliban are only
allowed to let people through here who
have foreign passports who have visas
and who have paperwork that is verified
i'm here without documents because a lot
of people that went to the us on
evacuation flights were civilians so i
thought if civilians are going and i
served in the army i should be eligible
to go too
everybody's going so i'm going to in my
house they won't leave me alone my wife
says get down there why are you so lazy
i leave the house every day so my wife
stops hassling me in a way to control
the crowd and try to figure this out
they've been looking through people's
paperwork at different locations around
kabul and then putting them on these
buses knowing that these people are
actually allowed to be on these flights
and they are prioritized to get through
and in the meantime they are trying to
control the crowds and keep people back
stop them from swamping so that these
buses can come through how they are
doing that is by shooting guns in the
air by using water cannons and by
beating people to push them back
i've been close to the gate three times
but because of gunshots and shouting it
makes everyone scared since i'm a woman
i don't have the courage to push past
them i'll do my best to get out even if
i get shot i will continue trying to get
inside the airport
now the taliban say that anybody who
wants to get through and wants to leave
and has the paperwork
that would allow them on these flights
can do so but they also tell us they
hope people don't they say that these
people many of them who are highly
skilled would be an asset to the country
going forward and that they hope that
they stay but in the meantime with only
six days left until these flights have
to end and we know that the numbers the
the number of flights will decrease in
the days going forward that uh the
crunch is on and a lot of these people
are trying their best to get through
into the airport today
well let's now speak to rosalind jordan
she's in washington dc with all the
latest from there roz the pentagon is
saying what 10 000 people are still left
to evacuate are they confident that
these airlifts are actually still on
track
well they say that they believe that
these evacuations are still on track
that they can get this work done by
august 31st but there is growing concern
because the pentagon says it does need
to draw down its remaining equipment at
the airport in kabul as well as remove
the remaining u.s troops who were
deployed to help with this evacuation
and so that's raising some question
about whether those who want or need to
leave the country will be able to do so
the pentagon spokesperson is john kirby
we will continue to evacuate
needed populations
all the way to the end if if
if we have to and we need to
if uh
if you're an evacuee that we can get out
we're going to continue to get get you
out so in those last couple of days
we will begin to prioritize
military capabilities and military
resources to to move out uh that doesn't
mean that um
that if if you're you're evacuee and and
uh
and you need to get out that we're just
we're not going to try to get you out
but that we will have to reserve some
capacity in those last couple of days to
prioritize the military footprint
leaving
now there's also this fact on tuesday
the u.s president joe biden said that he
had ordered the pentagon and the state
department to give him contingency plans
if they get to uh
or get close to august 31st and don't
see that the work of evacuating people
from afghanistan has in fact been
completed now while no one will say that
they're actually going to push past
august 31st the implication is there
that if they don't have everyone out of
country who should have been able to get
on a flight
it seems as if there's now the
possibility that that date could push of
course what's the big factor in this the
taliban says that the u.s government
made an agreement with it to remove all
troops by august 31st and that it
expects the united states to keep to its
word
rosalind jordan there with all the
latest from washington dc thanks so much
ross
well meanwhile hundreds of afghanistans
of afghans i'm sorry are trying to enter
pakistan at the token border crossing
but with no proper documents many of
them are unable to get through
osama bin javad has this report for us
from the pakistan afghanistan border
from turkey afghanistan i've just
entered torkham on the pakistani side
this is the main border crossing between
the two countries for trade and for
people as you can see taliban fighters
are manning all the border posts across
the country with neighboring countries
including central asian states pakistan
and iran and these fighters have been
telling us that they are allowing
everyone to cross the border now the
problem here as you can see hundreds of
people have been gathering every day
since kabul
came to the control of the taliban on
august the 15th and these people have
been trying to get inside pakistan the
pakistani authorities say that they will
only allow people who have the right
documentation to make sure that no
extremist elements no terrorist groups
or no infiltration of pakistan can take
place
my family and kids are across in
pakistan and we have been waiting at
this border crossing for one week and
will be here until we are allowed to go
as the trucks go back and forth uh
trying to earn a living in this area uh
for humanitarian reasons the soldiers
have not been stopping them uh but
they've been carrying cigarettes and
other things that they've been trying to
smuggle across the border and make a
quick buck
people have been saying they're
desperate not just to cross into
pakistan for safety but because they
have tribal ties on either side of the
line which divides the two countries and
they want to visit their families they
want to go and meet people who are
either sick and who've passed away but
so far if they don't have the right
documentation they're not going to be
allowed inside pakistan